بخصوص مدينه اريحا ما زالت العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه متواصله منذ نحو
النصف ساعه قوه اسرائيليه خاصه داهمت مخيم
عقبه جبر وتحاصر منزل على ما يبدو يتحصن
فيه مجموعه من المسلحين الفلسطينيين او
خليه فلسطينيه مسلحه القوات الاسرائيليه
قامت باطلاق بعض الصواريخ المحموله على
الكتف على المبنى وتنفذ الان خطه ما يعرف
بطنجره الضغط
يعني تطويق المبنى بشكل كامل واجبار
المسلحين على التسليم انفسهم هناك
اشتباكات مسلحه تدور في المكان الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني قبل قليل نقل اصابه لشاب
خطيره بالرصاص الحي في الراس وهناك ايضا
اصابه اخرى وما زالت الاشتباكات
والمواجهات المتواصله داخل هذا المخيم في
مدينه اريحا القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا تغلق
يعني تضع حواجز وتغلق مداخل المخيم بشكل
كامل هنا جنوب مدينه نابلس ربما كما ترى
ما زالت سيارات
وهذه التجمعات الفلسطينيه بسبب صعوبه
التنقل التعلم كان الالكتروني وهناك كما
قلت اغلاق كبير واغلاق للطرق ومنع
السيارات الفلسطينيين من المرور لتامين
تظاهره المستوطنين ما هي خطه هذه المسيره
مدى وراءها ايضا عبد الحفيظ وكيف يعني
يتحرك الفلسطينيون ربما اذا كان هناك من
دعوات لمواجهتها
[موسيقى]
يعني احتمال المواجهه ايضا خالد وارد بشكل
كبير لان هذه المستوطنين والمسيره ستدخل
من وسط بلده حواره من العديد من القرى
الفلسطينيه والتجمعات الفلسطينيه لذلك
احتمال المواجهه مع الاهالي الفلسطينيين
وارد بشكل كبير ولذلك نشرت اسرائيل
العشرات او مئات حتى من الشرطه والجنود
لحمايه هؤلاء المستوطنين اثناء مرورهم
داخل التجمعات الفلسطينيه طبعا
الفلسطينيون يضطرون لسلك طرق بديله طرق
جبليه وطرق وعره للوصول الى بيوتهم او
كراهم لان الشارع الرئيسي مغلق
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات